Right now, we're following new warnings
from Washington
to Beijing
about the Chinese spy balloon now
flying over the United States.
U.S.
officials are not ruling out
the possibility of shooting down
the balloon.
Brian Todd is working the story for us.
Brian, what are you learning about
spy balloons like this one
and how they actually work?
Wolf, analysts
say spy balloons have been used in war
as far back as the 1700s
through the American Civil War
and up to the wars
in Iraq and Afghanistan.
Experts say
they may look unwieldy,
but don't let that fool you
This is floating there.
That's what's the weirdest part about it.
That tiny white dot in the sky
can seem deceptive.
This suspected
Chinese spy balloon
experts say, is a vehicle
that's more impressive
than you might think.
Balloons have a long history in warfare
being used
for intelligence,
surveillance, reconnaissance.
And this is no different U.S.
officials say this balloon
now moving over the central U.S.
is the size of three city busses
and appears
to have solar panels on it,
as well as surveillance equipment.
Analysts say since the balloon likely
has no motor,
the solar panels would help
power the balloon
and to allow for an operator
to steer the balloon because any steering
mechanism would require
some degree of power as well.
Experts say
these balloons can fly
at altitudes of 60,000 feet to 50 miles
above the earth.
We asked analysts
what kind of surveillance equipment
this vehicle might have
and the capabilities of that equipment.
They'll have cameras
for imagery of sensitive sites.
They can have other sensors
that can collect signals intelligence.
So think about
eavesdropping on your cell phone.
These are these buildings
have been around for a long time.
And we ourselves in
the United States have used them
simply to monitor
the ground in Iraq and Afghanistan.
But with military satellites
having such sophistic
cated surveillance capability,
what would a spy balloon
have that a satellite wouldn't?
One, they fly at lower altitudes.
And the other big advantage
I think they have
is the persistence
they can just kind of
hang out and loiter over sites,
whereas satellites,
of course, are in low-Earth
orbit, are rotating around the earth.
And experts say
balloons are much cheaper
to deploy than satellites.
But the spy balloon, as possibly evidence
in this case, isn't infallible.
One of their biggest drawbacks
historically is
that they can just get carried
away by the wind.
We tried to use them
to spy on the Soviet Union
during the Cold War,
and that was our big problem.
So if it's not shot down,
how would a balloon like this
eventually come down?
Would it just be allowed
to crash somewhere
if they steer them properly?
They can just like you would
in a hot air
balloon over Santa Fe, New Mexico.
They would bring that down
in a very controlled descent.
Experts say
the spy balloon
has a future and possibly an ominous one.
They say it could be used
as a weapons platform,
possibly to attack cities
or static formations of troops.
As one analyst said,
there's no limit
to the kind of technology
you can stick
on the bottom of a balloon Wolf.
Look forward.
And warfare maybe in the future.
We'll see what happens.
Brian, thank you very much
for that report.
I want to bring in CNN's Fareed Zakaria
right now.
He's the host of Fareed Zakaria GPS.
Fareed, thanks for joining us.
As you know,
White House
officials have viewed
U.s.-china relations
as improving, following President Biden's
November
meeting with the Chinese president
Xi Jinping.
How has the presidents of this spy
balloon abruptly seemingly changed that
Well,
it points to the central dynamic
between the US-China relations,
which is domestic politics.
Look, the whole spy balloon aspect
reminds me of that,
that a scene in Casablanca, you know,
I'll be really that shocked
that the Chinese are spying on us.
We spy on the Chinese every day.
The Chinese have very sophisticated
military satellites
that spy on us all the time.
They're spy planes that do so.
I myself doubt very much
that this is as sophisticated
as people are saying. If it was.
Why the hell did it
veer off course
so dramatically as it did here?
There is very little as far
the intelligence people
I've talked to don't believe that
there is much additional capacity.
Again,
this is as as your report pointed out,
something that was used
in the French Revolution.
This is not exactly cutting
edge technology.
But more importantly,
of course, the Chinese spy on us.
We spy on them.
The purpose of Anthony Blinken's
visit to China was precisely to stabilize
a difficult relationship,
a competitive relationship.
The reason we have relations with other
great powers is not as a gift to them.
It's to secure our interests,
to preserve the peace,
to preserve stability
I don't understand
the purpose of canceling the trip,
the presence of a spy balloon,
let us assume it is.
That is even more
reason to have a conversation with them,
to figure out what guardrails
we can have
for a very difficult relationship.
So you think Secretary of State Blinken
made a major blunder in canceling
that trip?
I think
Secretary Blinken and the administration
are not reacting to China.
They are reacting to Kevin McCarthy
and Marco Rubio and Ted Cruz,
who have all used this as a as a way
to attack the administration.
Donald Trump is saying
shoot down the balloon.
So you have, you know,
basically a bunch of people on the right
who want to go to war because
because the Chinese
because they have suddenly discovered
that China spies on us
and the administration feels compelled to
in some way seem tough.
It's a very bad dynamic
because it fundamentally
stops as you said,
the whole point
was to try to have some kind
of serious conversation with the Chinese
about the many issues
on which we have serious disagreements
and problems.
I mean, we met with the Soviet Union
all the time.
It's you know, they were spying on us
throughout the Cold War.
We still met with them.
So what should the US response
to this balloon flying over
the United States have been
I think
Blinken should have gone
that disgusted
with them, talked about
we need a lot more arms control measures
with the Chinese.
We have a lot of procedures with
Russia still there, holdover
from the Cold War.
You know,
we we have the arms control treaties.
We have confidence building measures.
We have a hotline between Moscow
and Washington all to make sure
there aren't accidental events like this.
There is a miscalculation
because remember, China
also is a nuclear power.
It has intercontinental
ballistic missiles.
It has nuclear weapons.
And we want to stabilize
the relationship.
We want to make sure
that nobody is miscalculating.
So it feels to me like
that's all the more reason to go
and have serious conversations with them.
You know,
when I'm talking to them
as a gift to them
for some kind of good behavior,
we're talking to them
because they're the second
largest economy in the world.
And essentially the other
burgeoning superpower in the world.
Fareed Zakaria, as usual,
thank you very much for joining us in.